[Music]
the careful boys now have to decipher
you know there's a guy who has some
relationship problems with his wife okay
um his wife when they got together she
said that she's a bisexual
and that she very much would like to
have sex with him and another woman
someday that's what she promised that's
what she said however sounds fun now
all of a sudden now that they're a
couple years into their marriage
he was at the beach with her recently
and he's like hey or she the
wife commented first
that that woman looked pretty sexy i
liked when she said that so the man was
like would you like
me to try to figure out you know if
she's interested in having a three with
some with us and then she
broke the news to him that she doesn't
think she's into that anymore
that flip flopping ass lying ass what
the hell that's gas lighting well that's
gas lighting
why does she even comment on that lady
on the beach then you can't part-time
bisexualized part-time
sexual lies now this [ __ ] gentleman
would like to know
how can he help her get back to who she
used to be electrocution
get back to your original rules she lost
herself don't be so fake how much time
has passed since
years since those promises since those
empty promises yeah that's why you got
to keep maintaining gonna keep doing
threesomes on direct that's why she has
to
pursue her passion immediately or else
her dream dies yeah or is it or is it
one of those things to like bait them
into the marriage you know what i mean
it's like it's like yeah i totally want
children and then after it's like oh
yeah you know what it's gonna ruin my
career i agree with you i agree with you
women are evil you can't get married to
someone for a threesome though right
it's definitely a plus but she's but she
swore to god
that she would do that she did say that
it's a flexibility thing you got to keep
stretching or else you lose the
flexibility oh yeah she wasn't
stretching though you don't use it you
lose it right
but if you don't use being gay does that
mean you become straight then because
you go i ain't into the guys that much
anymore because you weren't sucking
enough dicks but the buy is flexible if
you're just into one thing you're not oh
well if you're like gay and you never do
anything gay then are you good i think
so yeah you're still gay i think so that
just means you can't get a date i think
it means that like you're yeah you're an
insult yeah you're intel gay
in cell games
think about like a 1950s gay guy who's
like all the way in the closet has like
four kids rock hudson yeah exactly bro
all that [ __ ] there's a lot of that
going on repressed closets but what if
you just never even had a male or female
because nobody wants you
yeah that's well then you get laughed at
don't you
my guy named joe joseph
he laughed at your [ __ ] face
threesomes are overrated anyway wow
speaking from experience how'd it go
yeah um is it too much to handle it's
stressful man what's so stressful though
that muscles are way more fun really
yeah because it's like two two one two
you know it's even two guys two guys
you can high five your bro four guys
four guys in a room high five bro
i've always met my friend two guys yeah
it's like nba jam
me and john stockton
he's on fire have you done that
legitimately yeah i've done a three i've
done four
how do you get that many homies to be
down
i've only done one but it's so fun
though yeah it was two dudes two chicks
yeah yeah i think i had to take viagra
it was a lot you get nervous first time
the guy in the couple their experience
you're like yeah they were swingers or
yeah swingers did they invite you guys
yeah yeah i met them on tinder oh nice
oh it's so fun man these are a setting
for did you switch swords back into the
sheaths different women you're swapping
swords
were you emotionally attached to this
one no oh good oh so you didn't even
care so it was like it was like were you
emotionally pulled out you're sorted and
you put it into sleep who was better who
was the better one that you had a better
connection with
was it the other guy's lady i've one of
the woman i brought i've slept with her
before so i probably know her body
better but the new woman was fun too did
you uh
were you afraid you were gonna come too
fast because it was so exciting yeah i
was afraid i wasn't gonna be able to get
it hard oh
yeah at first in the beginning i
couldn't but then he was like let's
relax you know it happens and then i
just got a bit of viagra all good you
took a whole pill or half of one don't
remember nothing took a whole pill did
you have to establish ground rules
you're a party animal man uh
ground rules
no the guy said he wasn't the gun
neither of us would buy for the guy but
the women would buy so that's fine he's
like if you accidentally enter my ass
it's understandable what happens
don't let it happen you're a human being
and people make mistakes
so while the girls were at it were you
just like
talking to the guy like they're hot huh
yeah
it's not high school yeah but
like what are you doing because they're
just like doing their thing and you're
just like yeah like they're [ __ ] you
can watch a bit but you don't go like
yeah bro
how about chitchat you guys do
you guys play fire sticks fire sticks
what's that you ever play first no no
see
in a threesome it's it's harder because
if the woman's pleasing the other woman
you feel like okay i need to do
something but but then it's like double
dutch
it's really hard to do in porn
logistically very hard to achieve like
[ __ ] someone from behind and that as
a woman is going down another one you
feel like you're interrupting them
because your head's going all yeah it's
like moving move you know but like if
there's two guys you know both [ __ ]
the woman they can occasionally make up
that's that's it's like shaking a guy
when he's trying to do a graffiti piece
[ __ ] dude
what if you are like i gotta rep the set
man
i think it's okay
[Laughter]
did you ever used to shake your friends
when they pissed
yes yes
yes that's a great past time you have to
so mad i'll still do that dude that's
funny
they just like swivel their hips when
they're trying to pee in the urinal how
does that night end though is it just
like all right bro that was sick
how to recognize it it was normal do you
fall do you guys do like beep there or
do you put your clothes on and say okay
i don't [ __ ] sleep in that bed like
four people have been on oh
that's not my house although the best
thing about having a foursome is you
know the guy who invited you there they
have a nice house because it's big
enough in london to have that space
you know for a foursome you know it's a
nice house do you guys is there is there
a competition like i'm not gonna finish
before he does oh no i don't i don't
think i think that'll be
that would be fun
so you come and go okay i'm done you
guys keep going ahead that's what the
violet is for the the what the right i
don't think viagra makes you i think if
on viagra you come you still you can't
get it hard again anyway oh really i
always thought it like wow i've only
taken one so i don't know yeah what do
you do then you come and you go in the
kitchen make some tea or something
we come at about the same time when the
other guys
he's more experienced so i let him lead
so when he comes out i'll come too you
know oh what was the duration how long
did this we went you [ __ ] a bit you take
a break a bit have some whiskey have
some wine watch top gear again yeah two
top gear is great
sip some tea
talk about the weather that's a good
intermission
is there a light that goes on
intermission time all right guys tea
whiskey top gear you're like the mclaren
460 has beat out the shelby gt wow
couldn't believe it
yeah it was a good time it's a good time
nice we're sexual maverick fun memories
so this guy do everything once right
yeah
this guy is saying that um basically uh
he so i told you about the idea that um
he commented on a girl with a bikini
i have a theory about this i think that
he
he was trying to reactivate this thing
she says i just want to be with you and
she's basically saying like hey pick me
[ __ ] you know what i mean like
you i know you want your little fantasy
and stuff but you better prioritize me
first i think she doesn't feel that way
here and that's what's going on because
he's like oh she's [ __ ] hot you wanna
[ __ ] her baby yeah yeah and i think it's
different because
if you were married and you want a
threesome just let her choose right let
her come up with it let her choose let
her have the idea yeah i thought she
would get you she didn't choose and then
she thought she was sexy but she wasn't
saying let's go [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
this oh
he was too like excited he wanted too
bad he's like wait a minute you like her
way too much what if you like her more
than me exactly and then she's like [ __ ]
that whole thing i don't want it i just
want you what do you think of that and
then he's just like oh good so he shut
up he should have like warmed into it a
little bit better instead of being like
hey should i ask her be like hey you
remember when you said that thing i
think it should be all up to her because
it i think it makes her feel unsafe she
feels like very much like oh okay so or
he should have read the sign slowly like
she's like oh that girl's really sexy be
like hey did you want do you want me to
go get a cocktail for us you know start
really easing into a fun environment
hey honey look quite bright
and you have to laugh like that by the
way
that guy's too excited
he's so smooth so he does it
you know i'm half heart already that's
crazy
and you mostly you but also if they
start talking together in their bikinis
i'm jacking off and i'm coming i'm done
[Music]
you